there'll be spider-man two and three it
won't be homecoming two and three almost
because we knew about the second one but
not the third one
yeah well now you know now you know
sorry marvel what
how excited are you also to possibly
wear the black symbiote suit eventually
down the line sometime not in the not in
the disney studios has it been uh
fishing for a spoiler it hasn't been
discussed the black symbiote suit yet
i'd love to work with
i think it would be great we've
definitely put the building blocks in
but actually in the version well i don't
want to talk about this because i might
think crying can sometimes be
really easy and sometimes it can be
really difficult the other day we were
doing a scene on spider-man 3 and i
could just turn it on i didn't i was
like this is amazing my brother harry
has a small little cameo in this film
where he plays a character called the
shaker kid any chance there's a
multiverse in which andrew garfield
spider-man and two maguire spider-man
and spider-man all meet together
i mean as a fan i would